i'm very happy jennifer aniston has a
new man in her life
it was a good time and no as much as we
are waiting for another
dreamy broad and gen moment this little
cutie has stolen jen's heart
chesterfield have you fallen asleep with
your bone in your mouth
i think you have meet lord chesterfield
the new member of her
four-legged family and it looks like
he's settling
in nicely we have the best time together
the friend star took to instagram on
sunday to introduce fans to her new
rescue puppy writing
he stole my heart immediately a huge
thank you to wagmore pets for the
incredible work you do
grateful you take such great care of
these rescues and find them their
forever homes
they're very cute when they're that
small and they have puppy breath and
then you realize that i have two and
that's
quite a handful laura chesterfield
already has siblings
jen is also a dog mom to clyde a
schnauzer mix
and sophie her pitbull jen was also
a dog mom to a white german shepherd
whom she shared with ex justin thoreau
but dolly died in july 2019.
jen and justin came together to
celebrate her life last summer
in july 2019 a source told et that the
exes
differed on a lot of things but one
thing they were always on the same page
about was their dogs
they loved their animals and felt
strongly about choosing rescue dogs
no expense was spared the dogs had great
care
people used to joke that the dogs had a
better life than they did
you